back to the futures Christopher Lloyd
went from being an a-lister at the top
of his game - pretty much disappearing
entirely for those of you who've been
missing him don't worry
he wasn't dissolved in dip or sent back
in time to the Old West here's what he's
been up to lately struggling actors will
typically take whatever parts are
offered to them in major studio films
then once they've had a run of
successful projects they'll often start
getting pickier this has been the reason
that many famous actors have suddenly
disappeared soon after hitting it big
there are no longer desperate so they
only worked when a role truly speaks to
them but strangely enough for
Christopher Lloyd just the opposite is
true if you check out his filmography
you'll see that he's still working
constantly and the reason we aren't
seeing him popping up in major films is
that he isn't picky at all he is stated
on multiple occasions that he doesn't
mind small roles in small projects for
instance in an interview with Metro New
York he said unless it's total garbage
all work whatever comes along the money
might not be fabulous but I don't mind
that even though he hasn't been a
recurring cast member on a big TV show
since his days on taxi Lloyd still
spends plenty of time on the small
screen albeit usually in brief guest
appearances for instance he appeared on
the Roseanne revival as Bev's comically
elderly boyfriend Luke he also showed up
in the Big Bang Theory as Theodore
a creepy vagrant who Sheldon rents his
room out to as part of a revenge plot
against Leonard if you go back a little
further Lloyd has no shortage of great
TV appearances he was in the hundredth
episode of Psych which was a loving Oh
wash to his film clue and also featured
several of his co-stars from that movie
he was also on an episode of Law & Order
criminal intent because apparently all
actors are required to appear on at
least one Law & Order show at some point
in their career band of course we can't
forget his regular gig on the
short-lived sitcom stacked alongside
Pamela Anderson Ohio area belt what I
came in
lloyd has also been spending plenty of
his time lately on social media his
platform of choice is Twitter where he
tweets under the handle at Doc Brown
Lloyd his feed largely consists of
chatting with fans retweeting Back to
the Future memes and speaking his mind
about our current political climate
Lloyd speed is certainly an entertaining
place to be but let's hope he can
remember to use the internet responsibly
we still want to see him on the big and
medium screens rather than spending all
his time on the smallest screen of all
over the past few years Lloyd has spent
a decent chunk of his free time
traveling around the country hosting
live screenings of his films followed by
Q&A sessions he's also no stranger to
the convention circuit including the
2016 Wizard World Philadelphia
appearance alongside is Back to the
Future co-stars Lea Thompson and Michael
J Fox Lloyd has never shied away from
appearing publicly or interacting with
fans while at Seattle's Emerald City
Comic Con in 2018 he spoke about how
gratified it was to hear how bands have
been affected by his work but the future
change their lives well they chose
certain careers because of the influence
of the movies keep an eye on your local
convention circuit even if you're not
seeing Christopher Lloyd much in movie
theaters anymore there are more chances
than ever to talk to him in person one
unfortunate reason that we're not seeing
more Christopher Lloyd is simply because
Back to the Future is probably never
coming back
Lloyd himself isn't the problem as he
still loves playing Doc Brown and cameo
appearances and other small occasions
all the Cubs are the playoffs yeah they
actually
but the producers are definitely against
it though and there's also the matter of
Michael J Fox as health issues Fox has
been battling Parkinson's disease
publicly since 1998 and though he's
acted regularly since then leading parts
in a new back to the future maybe more
than he could comfortably handle when
asked about the prospect of a sequel
director Robert Zemeckis told The
Telegraph oh god no I mean to me that's
outrageous especially since it's a good
movie
it's like saying let's remake Citizen
Kane who are we going to get to play
Kane what folly what insanity is that
why would anyone do that the truth is
that Christopher Lloyd was always
difficult to cast he has a unique energy
that is perfect for some very specific
roles so perhaps he was always destined
to be a mid-level character actor he
used to make up for the limited demand
for eccentric weirdos and big films by
playing a very wide age range bouncing
back and forth between older and younger
characters from film to film now that
Lloyd's becoming an old man for real his
options are getting more limited in an
interview with Metro New York he hinted
at the difficulties that have come with
getting older saying I once did a Q&A
for Back to the Future and some little
kid asks for the microphone and says mr.
Lloyd now that you're older do you miss
putting on old-age makeup Boychuk him
heartily at that precocious question
which hopefully means he's made peace
with getting up there in years check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]